hi my name is Jane Caroline I'm spending
a lot of time out of the office these
days with a sick mother I have two
laptops that you know a heavy laptop at
work and a heavy laptop at home but I
really need something portable that I
can access my office directly through
VPN with hi Jane I'm sorry to hear about
your mom but hopefully I can help with
your question if you use Microsoft
Windows to access your VPN which is
really just a fancy tech term for
describing how you access your office's
network remotely I would suggest a
windows 8 hybrid laptop tablet device
the assist transformer t100 is thin
light and also very cheap at three
hundred and fifty dollars if you just
need access to company websites for work
you might be okay with a Chromebook
though which is really just a standalone
laptop that runs the chrome web browser
the HP Chromebook 11 costs only two
hundred and eighty dollars now a lot of
VPN software like logmein is accessible
via ipad apps if you already have an
ipad you might want to check with your
company to see if that works if you
prefer a real keyboard bluetooth
keyboard screen cost as little as
seventy dollars hope that answers your
question and speaking of questions we
want to hear more of yours nothing is
too stupid to ask not even this yeah
Todd you've got a problem tweet us your
questions with the hashtag ask wsj d